biographie présentée par Azeb
Wolde-Giorghis.
- Elle était la troisième après
son nom que son père. Une
enfance qui semble plutôt gaie.
À 13 ans, rencontre le prince de
graisse et c'est le coup de
foudre.
Lorsque la seconde guerre
mondiale éclate, Élisabeth
s'enroule comme apprenti
ambulances et mécaniciens.
À 21 ans, et se révèle lors son
discours hockey, en Afrique duSa
monarchie.
- Je déclare devant vous que je
me dévoue entièrement à vous et
à notre grande famille
impériale.
- Sept mois plus tard, elle
épouse Philippe, qui devra
renoncer à ses titres royaux
craquer d'un noir, le mariage
aura duré 74 ans ne prendra fin
qu'à la mort du prince, en avril
2021. C'est en 1952, durant une
visite officielle au Kenya, que
la princesse après la mort de
son père, elle devient alors
règne.
Le couronnement est célébré à
l'abbaye de Westminster,
Ésasabeth n'a que 26 ans et
devient Élisabeth II.
En moins de six mois, la reine
se rend dans les Caraïbes, au
Moyen-Orient, en Afrique. Elle
verra l'éclatement de l'empire
britannique, l'indépendance des
anciennes colonies qui
deviennent états membres du
comme Well.
Il a été son secrétaire privé
pendant 12 ans.
À son jubilé, la reine réitère
son serment.
Même si ce serment a été
prononcé il y a longtemps, dit-
elle, je ne regrette rien.
Un dévouement à la publique
certes, mais plutôt absente
comme mè d de famille.
(en anglais)
- -ghb taille et mère de
famille, on lui reproche d'avoir
été plus préoccupé par les
affaires de l'État que par la
famille.
(en anglais)
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ce sont surtout les affaires
familiales qui font là une des
journaux. Le mariage très royal
de son fils le prince Chleles
avec lady Diana, un véritable
conte de fées au tout semble la
réussir. Ils ont deux fils,
William et Harry, mais quelques
années plus tard, le couple se
sépare, en 1996, c'est le
divorce. Linincesse Anne, la
seule fille de la reine, divorce
également après avoir eu ses
deux enfants. Le prince Andrew
se sépare aussi de sa.
La monarchie devient de plus en
plus iopopulaire.
La renne décrit 1992 comme taper
année, ses deux fils séparent de
leurs femmes et le château de
Windsor est détruit dans un
incendie.
Cinq ans plus tard, en 1904 et
17, la mort tragique de la
princesse Diana verse tout le
pays. La reine est absente, elle
est dans sa résidence de bal
moral avec son mari et ses
petits-fils. Le public ne
comprend pas, la popularité de
la monarchie et à son plus bas.
La reine sera alors à Londres
est libre un discours direct
diffusé sur toutes les chaînes
de télévision.
(en anglais)
- Les années passent et la reine
reconquiert le coeur des Anglai.
Et n'a plus à ses côtés sa
mère et sa soeur.
Le prince Charles se remarie
ecec son amour de jeunesse,
Camilla, la vie continue.
Son jubilé de diamant est
célébré, des millions de
Britanniques lui rendent hommage
- La dignité et avec elle
naturellement.
Ça, c'est parfait pour exécuter
les rôles qu'elle doit faire.
Elle est très réservée...
dans les émotions, et ça, c'est
un avantage.
- Stabilité malgré les coûts :
en 2019 de son fils le prince
Andrew doit faire face à la
justice parce qu'il est accusé
de la question sexuelle sur une
mineure. Puis, son fils Harry
quitte la famille à cause de
la...
la reine suit la devise anglaise
à la lettre.
Mais son coup le plus dur sera
certainement la mort du prince
la mort du prince Philip, le 9
Son confident de toujours, ce
sera une des dernières photos
officielles du couple.
Laeieine continuera à régner
gardera sa place particulière
dans le coeur des Britanniques.
Car ils n'auront connu quelques
monarques.
Ce sera un règne sur deuxsièclee
devoir